Now, here's, here's another one.
So when I retired from the navy and got
out and started the consulting business
working in one of my risk averse friends
that was staying in the military for,
it's it's welfare program,
right? It's a, it's a paycheck,
right? And he, the guy wasn't, you
know, he wasn't all fired up anymore,
but he was in and so he had a
mortgage to pay and kids defeats.
So he's just staying in and he kind of
looked at me when I was getting out and I
said, yeah man, I got bills to pay too,
but I'm going to go and get
after it somehow. And he said,
what are you going to do if it, you know,
if the business doesn't work
and you end up in a, you know,
you can come back in and I'm, what,
what, what are you going to do?
You won't be able to get back and
blah, blah blah blah. And I said, Bro,
worst case scenario, everything goes to
hell. Guess what I'm going to be doing?
I have an RV, I will be
in my RV with my family.
We'll be driving up and down the coast
of California raiding Jujitsu schools and
training and I'll be surfing and it's
all good and it won't cost me barely
anything to do that. My retirement
will cover to be good to go.
You got a back up plan like that. Let me,
let me rephrase that. If you
needed a backup plan like that
[inaudible] what would it be? This is,
this is one of my favorite topics. Uh,
so I would say that I have an infinite
number of backup plans and the way I
think about that is by doing
what I call fear setting.
So much like you just
said, looking at my goals,
the worst things that could happen,
the ways I can mitigate that in the
way I could get back to where I am now,
if all hell struck at once,
helps me to remove the
fear of taking these,
these steps that might paralyze me.
Otherwise. The second part is by say,
practicing fasting, practicing spending
no money for certain periods of time.
I don't fear,
I would say the top handful of things
that tend to stop people from taking what
they perceive as risks.
The other very important thing is that
risk has a very specific meaning for me.
And I realized early on that people
talk about risk tolerance, taking risks,
but if they don't define
it clearly it can,
it can end up being paralyzing
and how nebulous it is. So for me,
risk is very simple.
It is the likelihood of an
irreversible negative outcome.
That's it. So most things I do, even
though people look at it, they say,
oh my God, this guy's in vec
investing in speculative startups.
When it's just one guy in an
idea, man, he's a risk taker.
I don't view myself that way at
all. I view myself as if anything,
someone who's very, has taken a lot of
time to get good at mitigating risk.
I'm a risk mitigator. Uh,
and in the case of say,
speculative investing,
I am only using money that
I can comfortably to lose.
And for me, backup plan,
similar to yourself.
Sheena, throw my dog in an RV, get some,
get some instant oatmeal sleeping
bag. Yosemite's right in my backyard.
I don't know how to go find some
dirt bag climbers and hang out there.
Good to go. Yeah, go hang out with
my parents. Get to see more of them.
Go for a run in the woods. Yeah.
While I'm trying to figure
out the next step I ate.
Then you had that attitude when you were
taking more legitimate risks. I mean,
right now, obviously you're,
you're pretty good to go and, but,
but in the beginning when you moved
out to the west coast, you had,
you had to have this similar attitude
of, cause I know I did that, that,
that attitude for me freed me. Like, oh,
worst case scenario, I lose everything.
Cool. I still have my RV. It's paid
for. Yeah, we're good. Yeah, totally.
I had that added more surfboards and
any other human should ever have and not
knives and surfboards. We rolled deep. I,
I think I had that realization early on.
And of course when I first graduated
from school, went out to the west coast,
I did not have a lot of money.
I remember when I came out to California
for the first time for a job interview,
I couldn't afford a hotel.
I stayed at the fair techs
kickboxing gym on the second floor,
sleeping on a bunk bed with a tie
instructor sleeping above me and washed my
clothes in the sink. You
Go. And I was happy. I mean,
Eh, I was fully content. I didn't
feel like I was missing anything.
And uh, uh, but let's not kid ourselves.
I mean, when I first moved out,
it was 1999 this is at
the peak of the bubble.
Rental prices are out of control and I
was making 40 grand a year pretax and
yeah, and my, my office, my desk
was in the fire exit. I mean,
they was completely
illegal. I was, I had to,
I had a, a pretty slick setup,
but it was very low budget. And,
uh,
but really what I think freed me
on some level is realizing in this,
hopefully this doesn't sound
perkish or arrogant or whatever,
but no matter what difficulties
might be, follow me,
whatever, uh, unemployment
might come my way.
There are people with fewer resources,
with less education who have
figured it out before and survived.
So if dozens or hundreds or thousands
of millions of people have figured this
out, I'm going to come out
the other end, it'd be fine.
And so that was very reassuring to me.